the government have always said
that they protected care homes from the
start
but claims by dominic cummings
suggesting that wasn't true
have angered carers like laura hibbard
and anne clarke
who now want answers we're trying his
best to work in 12 hours a day
12 hour nights amount of deaths that we
saw
i'd expect transparency and being open
and honest
um and i think if they've failed in that
then people need to be held accountable
hi nick kelly how are you
back in april last year i met care home
manager kelly hopkinson
she lost 19 of her residents in under a
month
and told us what she made of matt
hancock's claim that they were being
protected
we're getting told that every staff
member in healthcare
and every resident regardless whether
they've got symptoms or not will be
tested
it's a lie now a year on
she's even more angry i will getting
phone calls from the hospital you
you have to take this resident i said
i'm not taking them i'm not putting
everybody in the home at risk
if it's proven that the health secretary
actually lied when he said that
discharges to care homes would be tested
what should happen
they weren't just a number in a bed or a
statistic to us
um but he does need taking to task
because like i said it could have been
avoided
what dominic cummings says is accurate
then by march the health secretary matt
hancock
was assuring the prime minister that
care homes would be protected
but the reality on the ground was very
different by march
i had already witnessed severe shortages
of ppe and a lack of testing
and by early april it was obvious that
patients were being discharged from
hospital without covert 19 tests
that practice continued until april the
15th
by which time it was too late
helen keenan's mum kathleen had covered
when she was discharged from hospital to
a care home
she later died as did half of her fellow
residents
i'd like to know why he doesn't think he
needs to apologize
i think that's a very poor reflection on
a man in his position
the government insists it did all it
could to protect care home residents
but the coming's allegations if true are
serious
and may prove significant when it comes
to understanding
what went wrong nick martin sky news